à moi c'est un manque d'hygiène ouais
c'est à dire rible aura
transpiration
horrible terminé il est déjà tombé sur
quelqu'un vraiment il ya vous avez été
étonné il ya eu un rêve un manque
d'hygiène a c'est arrivé dans la salle
de sport et tout était et hewitt a été
étonné quand même parce qu'il est comme
quoi vraiment tu dois te sentir
l'haleine le truc non mais est ce que un
partenaire voilà un jour a dit ah ouais
merde non non non ça me faisait
m'arriver s'améliorer parce que s'il
arrive chez moi c'est qu'il est propre
nom
éléphant bleu
non mais avant il y avait plus d'étapes
quand même tu prends un verre tu papote
du machin tête approchent ils ont dû
parler un petit peu dans le coup
comment tu t'appelles tu ça et ouais
voilà moi ma verve et une parfumerie
donc j'ai le nez très développé ouais
c'est bien sûr pas que manning a pas que
le nom
me sentir si des boisés printanier bien
sûr boisé musc ambré oui absolument
laisser le charme agit non mais ses fans
est fou c'est quoi un tue l'amour pour
vous le plus grand tunnel mont béatrice
m avec gilles parce que quelqu'un qui
fait un numéro de la porte ouverte et
qui nettoie pas ces toilettes c'est pas
possible point numéro 2 qui s'appelait
dit ce numéro 6 a number two ses
poubelles vomissent cas d'accord number
two c'est la grosse émission
moi je dirais que c'est plutôt alors je
rejoins tout à fait
mattel mat mais c'est mathieu les
matières et la triste mais je pense que
c'est un peu son global entre beaucoup
plus large à savoir dans le style de la
personne ça se voit tout de suite
qu'elle en ait qui n'est pas soignée et
moi j'ai beaucoup de mal avec sa voix là
bas j les bâtonniers et s'il est très
soigné s'il est très soignée et très
soignée alors j'étais très soigné et il
était chez le médecin encore hier
dans le cloud gratuit d'amour c'est vous
j'ai expliqué pourquoi
j'étais dans une chambre avec une amie
et d'un coup vous avez surgit nu dans la
chambre avec une lampe de poche et ça
m'a coupé tout envie de donner suite
alors c'était pas une lampe de poche
j'enseignais
ça m'a traumatisé je n'arrête pas d'y
penser j'ai des flashs il a d'emblée un
soir à la maison avec une amie et j'ai
débarqué je tape à la porte et mais
qu'est ce que vous faites sortez de
larmes de poche ouais vous ai débarqué
nu ça en plus des jacuzzis partiellement
racheté pas dû si vous étiez est donc
vain d'acheter alors à rien ça va ça m'a
coupé l'appétit c'est vrai mais c'est à
dire tu as fait
j'étais sous le choc et j'essaie de
reprendre une vie normale depuis six ans
[Rires]